- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Don't do it, don't do it!
- Oh
- No!
(creepy music)
- My parents would not
let me have this game,
so I would like, "I'm gonna go study!"
- I do not like scary video games.
I don't like the ghosts in Pac-Man.
- I hate horror games so much.
The enjoyment I have is watching
other people play horror games.
(8-bit music)
- Before The Walking Dead,
before zombie apocalypse
became such a thing,
Resident Evil scared the crap
out of you.
Dude, there's some headless guy
just propped up
- Oh no.
- against the alleyway.
Oh my god!
Okay, sorry, I just freaked out
'cause I thought that guy was dead
and he was just lying there,
but then he just like rose up, was like,
nope, I'm coming after you now.
Do not want.
Oh!
- Oh shit.
- All the zombies!
(laughing)
Damn, okay.
- Go, go!
- No, no!
- Oh, god.
Please, please, run!
- No!
Ooh,
okay.
- God, this game, man.
(8-bit music)
- I didn't even like passing
the arcade seeing that,
it would creep me out as a kid.
I was too young for this.
- In Dragon's Lair, you
play Dirk the Daring.
Jesus Christ, already?
- Yeah.
- Sword.
Oh, son of a bitch!
- See, usually they show
'em like eh, and he's dead.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're right.
Do they not have all the dead cuts here?
- I bet they censored this.
- Censored it?
(grunting)
- Ah, dammit.
- Kay.
- Ah!
See, this is why you
watch big kids crying.
(laughing)
- When Dirk dies, and sort
of shows up as a skeleton,
he looks so disappointed in you.
There we go.
- That's the guy.
- That's the one.
- That's what I remember.
- Is this really on easy?
Did we make sure this was on easy?
We did?
- But it's definitely censored,
'cause you saw his dick in
the arcade all the time.
(laughing)
(8-bit music)
- I love Zelda and the Zelda franchise,
but this gives me the chills.
- Oh, I get a little hat.
- Oh god.
- I'm still the Deku kid or whatever.
(screaming)
Look at his eyes!
He's comin' for you.
I don't like this.
Oh, no!
- It's talking.
(laughing)
- 12 hours!
- At night!
- Okay, oh yeah, that's so said.
They're having a festival,
and then the moon kills them all!
Oh,
no!
The ground is shaking.
The ground is shaking
Oh my god, I have distinct
memories of when I was a kid,
I really hated the rumble pack
that you put on the bottom,
and it would start shaking
when the moon was coming.
- Oh.
- That guy.
- He's supposed to be
cute, but in the darkness,
everyone's horrifying.
- I always thought that guy was an onion.
- Oh man.
This is so stressful.
- That's exactly what it is.
- I don't know what to do.
Scientifically, this is completely,
like, ridiculous.
The moon would never drop that slowly.
- It wasn't as scary, because
I think when I was younger,
the graphics were amazing,
and now you see like cones
and squares like walking around.
- You wanna find another
game that holds up
for 35 years, you gotta go
to like Monopoly or tennis.
- Which are both terrible games.
- They're not great.
- Yeah.
- I think there are a lot
scarier games out now.
Five Nights at Freddy's messed me up.
(bright fanfare)